top lots of your fans in the audience a
few fans everywhere but is it always the
same what do people mostly ask you but
what women mostly say to you and shout
out to you when they see you oh it it
they used to yell
houston we have a problem that you see
all that the young run Forrest run
that's a biggie but now they just they
just yell is it the same everywhere like
if you if you're in you know I think yes
yeah evidently Wilson is a universal
language world they don't bother dubbing
into any other life so it's in it's in
Hindi it's in Japanese Chinese this time
that in Forrest Gump the famous voice to
use as as Forrest it came from a
specific person the young Michael Connor
Humphries who played young Forrest Gump
we were trying to Bob Zemeckis came in
he said hey we got a problem on this
there's Michael right there the Sally
and Sally and Michael oh he was a very
young man he's now a veteran he served
in Afghanistan
Bob said oh we got a problem here you
have to teach this kid how to talk the
way you want to talk and I thought why
don't why don't I just talk the way he
talks right now and so we started
hanging out with him and he was from
Mississippi deep in Mississippi and he
had this he had this hard G at the end
of his if they said it wasn't thinking
it was thinking it wasn't making it was
making and said what does what does your
father do my god my my dad it makes
grace that's what he said and he said
he'd make I don't understand this Greece
something you make yes he says what do
you do with Greece well Greece goes into
all different sorts of products like
what products Oh Greece goes into
lipsticks
that was like well I'm not this is it
this is it
so somewhere I have cassettes hours and
hours of me just making chitchat with a
very young michael banck on but he
doesn't talk like that anymore no no no
he doesn't I was just uh you know we
have seven eight years old he was a
young man and that's that's that was the
vernacular that we spoken and it was
priceless that's adorable and of course
a huge success for you and the year you
when you're using that was your second
Oscar was their first well yes yes it
was if I put it this way it was my last
one but it was 1995 and that was a very
special year for the man sitting beside
you Peter Capaldi yes because that was
the year you were lost over there I won
an Oscar yes for a little short film I
didn't even know that they gave Oscars
for short films but I'd made this little
short film because I was interested in
filmmaking and the next thing I knew I
was being telephoned and being told that
you're nominated for an Oscar we didn't
even have any money we didn't know how
to get over there all right but so we
managed to cobble together of money to
get over there
and we find ourselves at the Oscars with
yourself but and lots of other film
stars and they call my name and I got up
on the stage and I looked down and it
was a huge auditorium like this and it
just looked to me as if it was full of
um you know an Arnold Schwarzenegger
look-alike look-alike a Tom Hanks look
like except that was the real thing and
it was sort of orgasmic I don't know how
it was for you but for me
what I knew is my last Oreos well it
wouldn't last because obviously when
you've just made a little short film it
doesn't have quite the same impact on
your career not half as an actor so that
just confused when three billion people
saw you yeah but as you know they take
you backstage and they put you on a kind
of conveyer belt and they take you into
like a hangar which has got the world's
press in it and they put you on a stage
and all those pictures you see if people
holding up there Oscar they're sort of
taken on that stage and then they say
would anyone like to talk to Peter
Capaldi winner of the short film for
1995 have you got
what is the theme of this show we don't
have we got one because it looks like
they're pretty easy to get yeah
let me beam them you because I haven't
finished yet all that great fries even
if you just win for a short film they
treat you that you were there we were
booked on economy to come back to London
because obviously we've done that so far
or back and I thought if I turn up at at
the airport Los Angeles Airport
I'm plate plates my Oscar surely I'll
get upgraded I didn't it was great we
handed right everybody in the economy
held up the Oscar like a Night at the
Opera people in the Titanic underneath
we enjoyed the Oscar chap but
I hate I go to the ward for that he won
the hearts of the nation when he swam
the channel for charity
we're not recording toy store at 4 so we
were doing that it takes a long time boy
you're not proud of your lad back a 42
million books of this these days he just
might win an Oscar